أنا جالس في الصباح ، أعتقد أنني
استمعت إلى Tom Steiner على الأرجح 500
مرة ألف مرة ثلاثة آلاف
مرة لا أتذكرها ، لكن غالبًا
كان Tom Steiner مهمًا بالنسبة لنا في إنشاء
MPSP
لأنه بدا سيئًا للغاية عندما قمت
بترميزها لأول مرة.  من أشهر أغاني سوزان فيجا ،
مطعم Tom's diner ، وقد
ساعد ذلك في إنشاء تنسيق الصوت mp3
الذي قتل بشكل أساسي القرص المضغوط ولكن من
الأفضل أن يوضح لنا كيف أدى مسار cappella
إلى ظهور مشاركة الموسيقى عبر الإنترنت
أكثر من الرجل الذي أنشأها ،
اسمي  لقد كان كارل يعمل ، يعرفني معظم الناس
لمشاركتي في
اختراع وتطوير mp3 ، لذا في
الواقع ، يطلق علي بعض الناس اسم والد
mp3 في الثمانينيات ، كان Carl Heine
جزءًا من فريق يعمل على تطوير طريقة
لضغط الموسيقى بينما لا يزال
الاحتفاظ بجودة عالية ، وهو شيء بدا
مستحيلًا في ذلك الوقت ، كان ترميز الكلام
راسخًا بالفعل ، ولكن إذا
حاولت ترميز الموسيقى باستخدام خوارزمية ترميز الكلام هذه ،
فقد بدا الأمر فظيعًا في
يوم من الأيام  رأيت مقالًا
ناقشوا فيه مكبرات الصوت المختلفة
وكيف اختبروا قالوا إنهم اختبروا أن
أكابيلا هو توم شتاينر من ccd لذا
قرر كارل هاين وفريقه استخدام
نفس الأغنية لاختبار أحدث
خوارزمية ضغط ولكن عندما فعلوا
ذلك تمكن من ذلك  تدمير الأغاني بصوت فيغاس
، لنرى ما إذا كنت قد لاحظت الاختلاف
في الصباح في العشاء في
الزاوية ، فأنا أجلس في الصباح
عند العشاء في الزاوية بينما كانت
الخوارزمية الخاصة بهم تعمل جيدًا لمعظم
الآلات ، كان هناك صوت واحد
لم يتم حله  ومع ذلك ، فإن الصوت البشري
سرعان ما أدركوا ما إذا كان بإمكانهم الحفاظ
على جودة الصوت على نسخة مضغوطة من
susan whoa ،
ثم يمكنهم ضغط أي
مسار موسيقي والانتقال إلى العام المقبل على ما
أعتقد أو نحو ذلك ليكون مصدر إزعاج كبير لنا
بعد بعض التعديلات  هنا وهناك قاموا
بضبط الخوارزمية الخاصة بهم وولد mp3
لنا عندما انفجر mp3
ووجدنا أنه كان أحد أكثر
المصطلحات التي تم البحث عنها على الإنترنت كان رائعًا.
ly لقد فعلنا ذلك وفي الواقع
يستمر هذا الشعور حتى يومين
وأحيانًا يجب أن أقول أنه منفصل
عن الاثنين إذا نظرنا إلى mp3
وعالم الصوت الرقمي اليوم لدينا شيء بسيط
يعمل mp3 في كل مكان لذلك في المرة القادمة
نحن  بث أغنية تذكر أن تشكر
Susan Vega و Carl Heine
والدة ووالد mp3